police in paris say that four people
have been injured two of them seriously
in a knife attack near the former
offices of the satirical magazine
charlie hebdo
we believe in the last few moments
according to the authorities there
a police source telling the reuters news
agency that a agency that the suspect
has been apprehended they were
originally looking for two suspects who
were on the run but in the last few
moments a source
telling the reuters news agency a
suspect has been apprehended there skies
europe correspondent adam parsons
joins us now on the phone uh adam uh
what more do we know about this and of
course the location uh highly emotive
for residents of paris and people who
remember 2015.
yes that's right that this is an attack
on
uh in the area near the former offices
of
of charlie hebdo of course at the moment
uh police in paris not able to
categorically say that the two things
are linked what our what we understand
is that there were two people involved
in this that they used
uh knives one of them having a cleaver
one of them having a machete
uh and attacked people four of them
injured two of them having what are
described as
life threatening injuries so clearly in
a very very
uh serious condition now this comes at a
very significant moment because the
trial of those alleged to have
uh have supported the charlie hebdo
attackers in 2015 is ongoing in paris
uh at the moment that trial just before
it began you'll remember
charlie had this french quite edgy
satirical magazine
uh reprinted a series of cartoons that
have caused a considerable
uh offense previously and what was seen
as
uh as a very provocative exercise
and tensions have been running quite
high
in some places criticism of the magazine
for doing that so i'm saying it
it inflamed uh tensions back in 2015 the
officers of course
uh were attacked uh 12 people killed and
then that precipitated
uh other attacks in a jewish supermarket
you will remember that the perpetrators
themselves were killed the people on
trial now those
alleged to have supported them and and
then
of course we all remember that following
those attacks there are a wave of
terrorist attacks across
europe that followed charlie hebdo has
has now
moved out of those offices but clearly
i think it police are going to draw
parallels between the 2015 attack and
what has happened here the french prime
minister jean-claude
is now cut short of visit to uh one of
the paris suburbs to take
direct control of the response of this
in the interior ministry and as you said
we understand that one person has been
apprehended
but if early reports are correct that
means that there is one other person
that police are still looking for adam
thank you
yes as adam said one person possibly
still being looked for by police and the
school children
in the area we're hearing around this
attack are being kept indoors at the
moment according to one city hall
official so still very much an ongoing
situation there in paris adam parsons
thank you for that